l'ancien président équatorien rafael
correa mis sur la touche et son parti
suspendu
la requête a été lancé par pablo cheli
della torre contrôleur général de l'état
est proche de l'actuel président et les
lignes moreno en cause selon lui des
irrégularités dans la procédure
d'enregistrement une suspension dénoncée
par l'ancien héros du mouvement pour
l'engagement social le mps qui pointe du
doigt les responsables une atteinte à la
démocratie
selon lui une fois de plus ils nous
volent la démocratie le cn a cédé aux
pressions de ses lits romo et le
gouvernement va éliminer illégalement et
prématurément notre parti n'oubliez
jamais les noms de ceux qui ont fait ça
à time acero cabreira pita et vers des
photos
condamné à huit ans de prison pour
corruption dans son pays et interdit
d'exercer toute activité politique
pendant 25 ans rafael correa est exilé
depuis 2010 est en belgique où il a
demandé l'asile politique après avoir
dirigé l'équateur de 2007 à 2010 est le
parti de l'ex président a annoncé avoir
déposé un recours auprès du tribunal du
contentieux électoral pour demander le
limogeage de pablo cheli pour ingérence
dans le processus électoral
pablo cheli à l'origine de la requête
contre le mcs a nié toute ingérence dans
le déroulement de l'élection
mais l'avis du contrôleur général de
l'état n'est pas partagé par tout le
monde sur les réseaux sociaux où est
apparu le hashtag destitution pablo
cheli autre réaction celui du groupe de
puebla composé entre autres de président
en exercice et d'ancien président dans
un communiqué le groupe dénonce une
judiciarisation de la politique
les membres du groupe de puebla
expriment leur profonde préoccupation
face à l'état de vulnérabilité
démocratique mis en place par le régime
du président lenin moreno celui qui est
considéré par certains comme une figure
de l'anti-impérialisme sud américain ne
pourra donc pas participer aux élections
présidentielle et législatives de 2000
21 ha d'ici là les partis politiques
suspendu elle dispose d'un délai de dix
jours pour présenter leurs cours
respectifs